hello everyone this game was played in
1991 it was played in Tilburg
Netherlands between Nigel short and Yun
Timur and it features the most amazing
King marched by Nigel short and I
believe this is the first game with the
aliens defense showing on my channel but
we've before I show you the game I do
have a request I want to ask of you
as you can see in the quote above the
board
my sister is having a baby it will be a
baby boy so she and her husband asked me
if I could help them come up with a name
but as it turns out I really suck at
naming babies so I thought maybe maybe
some of you have a nice creative idea
for a name and it doesn't matter she's
from Croatia but her first daughter has
an Indian name so any name it doesn't
matter where you're from will be more
than welcome so if you feel like
suggesting please do suggest so yeah on
to the game like I said this is young
team and this is Nigel short vs. young
team on 1991 let's see this game we have
efore Knight to f6 II five nights 2d 5d
four so already we we see the Alekhine's
defense
we have d6 Knight to f3 g6 and Bishop to
c4
we have Knight to b6 now attacking this
Bishop and the Nigel plays Bishop to b3
but in this position there is a fun
variation I sometimes I play this in
board games and also sometimes in blitz
games I sometimes play Bishop captures
on f7 and after King captures on f7
Knight to g5 check and well whatever
black plays for example came to g8 I
play e6 and like it's better in this
position but it's it's a very fun line
to play for white and especially under
load a lower time controls it tends to
create an interesting game but of course
this is a game of classical time format
so after a night to be six nigel played
Bishop to b3 we have a Bishop to g7
Queen to e2 Knight to c6
we have castles castles and h3 not
allowing Bishop to g4 we have a five
threatening a four and I
place a for himself so we have D captors
on e5d captures any file in our night to
D for attacking the Queen the bishop and
also the night so natural doesn't want
to give up this light square bishop for
example if he moves the Queen this
Bishop is going down so of course he
captures night capture Sun before we
have Queen captures on D fourth and our
rook to e1 defending that be five pawns
so it's a pretty standard position that
derives from the aliens defense and well
this is okay for both players we have E
six
Knight 2 d2 and we have Knight to d5
this is a pretty good square for the
knight also Knight to f4 is ready if
nigel allows it we have Knight to f3 now
Bishop is covering this f4 square we
have Queen to c5 and Queen to e4 and the
Nigel's Queen is occupying a beautiful
Central Square D 4 Square and diamond
doesn't like this so he plays Queen to
b4 he wants to exchange Queens but we
have Bishop to c4 and I Joe really likes
his Queen and e4 we have night to b6
trying to get rid of that bishop but
Nigel plays b3 he doesn't mind doubling
up his pawns if his Queen can stay on e4
so we have knife captures be captured as
uncie 4 and we have rook to e8 so T man
does have a bishop pair now but this
efore Queen is really powerful
we have rook to d1 Queen to c5 and Queen
to h4 now you have to see that nigel is
guarding this d8 square twice he's ready
to play rock to d8 if needed and also
Bishop h6 is well an idea here we have
b6 preparing to develop the light square
Bishop this will be a very powerful
diagonal for this light square bishop we
have a Bishop to e3 now with an attack
on the Queen Queen to c6 and now Bishop
to h6
natural ones to exchange this dark
square Bishop timin of course that
doesn't allow this he plays Bishop to h8
and we have rook to dat now now
attacking this rook and also well it's
it's
it's very good to have your rockin da
and the eight if you're white
so Bishop to be seven now notice that
this Bishop and queen are eyeing this G
2 squares so this night can never really
move
we have rook a to d1 doubling up on the
D file and here we have a bishop back to
g7 we have rook 8 a rook a to d7 and we
have roped the f8 now adding protection
to this F 7th worse f7 point if it ever
gets attacked a natural place Bishop
captures on g7 Kim captures and g7 and
rook one to d4 preparing this rook to
come help with the attack but we have
rook 88 we have Queen to f6 check King
to g8 and we have h4 natural really
wants to play h5 so teaming doesn't
allow would of course he plays h5 5
himself and this is the this is the
critical position of the game as you can
see well black doesn't really have a
useful move he can play there is well
pretty much any move he plays isn't
isn't a good move he can go for Bishop
to c8 but this well this would result in
a draw but white white it doesn't have a
good move to play either for example
there's no way for this rook to ever
help with the attack because this rope
would be hanging the knight can't really
move because Queen captures and g2 is
checkmate so it's not that easy for
white to come up with a plan to continue
the attack but nigel finds one and it's
well it's brilliant
Nigel plays King to h2 and I'm pretty
sure Tim and didn't realize what's the
idea behind King to h2 maybe he thought
that Nigel was just trying to give him a
move you know give him a chance to
blunder or you know worse in his
position and well if if demon realized
what Nigel's plan was he would have
played something like Bishop to c8 and
this this would force this would force
white to go for route to d8 and well
this would have been an equal position
black could play this but as
timin didn't realize the idea behind
king to h2 he played
rook rook the c8 just a waiting move and
now nigel played kink to g3 and well
even in this position
well my engine says that this is a
completely drawn position and that white
cannot win this so I am interested if
you have an engine what does your engine
think but here Timman realized what was
Nigel's idea and he quickly returned the
rook to e8 but now it's too late
Nigel already plays King to f4 and now
team undoes play Bishop to see it but
it's very much too late for it for ideas
like this we have kicked the g5 by short
and in this position well aunt Iman
resigned the game because there is no
defense there is no defense against King
to h6 if well if black were to stop this
for example with King to h7 then this
this is losing rook captures and f7 is
here and this is over or yeah maybe not
even rook captures n f7 maybe Queen
captures and g6 is even better so yeah
definitely definitely a beautiful idea
for example King to h8 check here we
have here King captures and there is no
normal moves for black rock the g4 is
coming and well even if fived and simply
Queen Queen to g7 checkmate but it
didn't come to this after King to g5
yanti man resigned the game and well
this beautiful King March game was
created so yeah this is the game and
yeah if you are ever in a position like
this and your opponent your opponent
plays a move like King to h2 don't don't
quickly assume that it's you know just a
nonsense move maybe he's playing maybe
he's planning a nice trip for asking so
yeah yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank John
Warner trident games and beat been eager
for a contribution to my channel I
really appreciate it thank you guys and
yeah if any of you do have any
suggestion for a baby name feel free to
put one in the comments section below so
yeah thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon